これじゃあ肇社長ぞ
山なり皆さん上野行ったことありますか
ちょっとわかりますか
行ったことありますか行ったことありました前やったことあるんですけどもう色々数字
が帰ってやって同じ色同じ数字だったらどうしていけるカード苦労って言うとか相手に
枚聴かせるカードとカリバーン
10寸盤買えずカートとか次の出さなきゃいけないと飛ばすたいっていう
いろんなお様カードがある中で進めていくんですけども
今ここに実物があるんですけどもう詠唱プレイヤーは1人7枚ずつカードを持って
ゲームが進んでいきます
スプレー
でしょ7位だったはい勝負が早いんがいいか早いよね
いやをするぞ早いんだよ早いんだったんで今回もう重要葉を準備したんですねず4
かける112でけんクンがいくら言うのがあるので御一人で100万円っっでこれもう
1本
ことによって読み新しい展開が見えるかもしれないといって感じダウンのでちょっと
今回この4人で右脳を持てるた100枚でやっていこうと思います
行くぞ
えっおっぱいすげえやって1500枚布ハートの言葉に出ました
もう詳しい
葉山ざらめな2つ
[音楽]
ただのわかんない者が地域によってなんですけど1枚しか出せないところ奪還とせると
かっ
同じスーツとか同じ
姉どうだったうちは1枚しか出せなかっに22が出たら自分はに1ましたちょっと未央
奈前もって言っても1枚しかたくなかっ
俺の家は俺の村ではから近く
俺の村では一緒にいたせましょう
6州の村でも一緒に出せますと
星野健良
2せることでしょうか入った同じ政治とか食ったらも出していくから
ずロっという3枚パー死んだしたら次の人は次郎シックてやる
はいやってみましょうおろしがいますアジアで a
the まずは皆さん100前
とっていきますはい勉学バレますねんっ
いって
にっ
10人
ja 10中
rea
よし
自分で2書って見ないことですねこれは強いは a 6匹めちゃいいや俺も低いよとも
負けてないと思う
[音楽]
最初はグーじゃんけん4
y 校でしょ会えにこれでしょ愛甲でしょ
あいこでしょあいこでしょ
一番
最初はグーじゃんけんほいないくるソンファれる時計回りのがいいんだよ
1番2番作ったらリリース切符とはっはっはっちゃ
いきますはいっ
お会いしますはいうんっ
wh
ana
血球入ってる本館かいきますはい2枚入っ
上部れ3枚付
そう
みんなすごいベル
大
[拍手]
好きプーきっスキップ
うんうん
ああああああ
どうぞ持って行った
はいここは1万円です
まさかあっ
いいいいいい
ああああああ
恋ず大4
うん
ああああああ
[音楽]
ブーブー位
ん十よっ
26週だってまいりました
なんで16枚どうぞに収録前1
にっ
一応買って来た
ni
ムーラン
皆さんもこの緩い展開に飽き飽きしてきた頃だと思います
れてある撮ろうつー
はい1枚
[音楽]
このか忘れますシックオンリーとでいいと音悪くって
ツール潤
ん
持ってレバー
水憶えています
[拍手]
もう
あとなるな1416タグにを浸す4
2二重黄色ろろーと言うなら出してもいいので
じゃあや後こういうではないのですここでこれドローン4
それは黒4しかないと24でござる
サンズに3640
4417年52 a
ありません
[音楽]
nan nan
もう持ってなかったの
おめーは経た
居住地52号
[拍手]
色がいい
海の